herkunft eines feuerballs geklärt
erhöhter medikamentenmissbrauch und
welcher durchbruch bei der heilung von
asthma gelungen sein könnte
das sind drei der fünf themen jetzigen
klick zum top 50 fireball entstammte
riesige masken am 19 april 2014 konnten
kameras des finnischen fireball networks
den flug eines feuerballs nahe der
finnischen grenze zu russland
aufzeichnen
auf höhe des anschlusses verschwand das
brennende gestein es wenige flugbahn von
meteoriten konnten derart festgehalten
werden
mit hilfe des materials konnte man teile
des gesteins die der feuerball auf
seinem flug verlor finden und genauer
untersuchen die gesteins teile setzen
sich aus h5 konkreten zusammenhang von
ried ist ein üblicher aus kohlenstoff
bestehende stein metroid so forscher
ceska geologica schlusspaar josef maria
trikot von der spanische
forschungsorganisation csc berechnete
jetzt zusammen mit seinen kollegen
mittels des videomaterials die flugbahn
des meteoriten die berechnung
ermöglichte es auf die abstammung des
feuerballs zu schließen er hat sich der
theorie nach von einem großen der erde
nahe gelegenen asteroiden abgetrennt
durchmesser des aski in der es beträgt
in etwa 400 meter also wirklich ein
ziemlicher brocken
aufgrund der schnellen rotation des um
die erde kreisen als soliden trennten
sich gesteinsbrocken und schossen in
richtung erde besorgnis erregt die
erkenntnis bei den forschern vor allem
weil sie eine analogie zu dem 2014
entdeckten 116 beobachten konnten
116 kam der erde bedrohlich nahe und
stellte zuerst eine beachtliche gefahr
für die erde dar
auswertungen des minor planet center in
cambridge zufolge käme der 116
in den nächsten 150 jahren der erdkugel
nicht beängstigend nahe bereits 2013
traf ein mit werde aktuell werden circa
2.000 hast du ihn nicht aus den augen
verlassen um einen möglichen
zusammenstoß mit der erde frühzeitig zu
erfassen
dann die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen zu können benötigen die forscher
noch weiteres wissen über die flugbahnen
solcher geschosse medikamentenmissbrauch
am arbeitsplatz ungeachtet der
nebenwirkungen greifen immer mehr
arbeitnehmer zur medikation um im
arbeitsalltag mehr leistung erbringen zu
können
emotional gefestigter zu sein stress zu
minimieren oder andere faktoren zu
entkräften
dem report zufolge der dak krankenkasse
nahm der missbrauch von medikamenten die
nur mit rezept erhältlich sind zu dem
jahr 2008 berichtet der
gesundheitsreport von 4,7 prozent setzt
seine 6,7
neben den 67 prozent wird von einer
dunkelziffer von 12 prozent ausgegangen
männer greifen vor allem aus gründen der
leistungserwartungen sowohl im job als
auch im privaten bereich zu pillen
frauen um emotional gefestigt zu sein
und um entspannter an die anstehenden
herausforderungen heran zu gehen bisher
galt die führungsebene als risikogruppe
für berufsbezogene
medikamentenmissbrauch die aktuellen
zahlen des gesundheitsreports der dak
gesundheit zeigen jetzt aber dass es
viel mehr anders herum ist je höher der
bildungsstand ist desto seltener greifen
die angestellten zu tabletten
rund 85 prozent der schlicht
beschäftigten arbeitnehmer und etwa 51
prozent der führungsebene nehmen eine
solche medikaments ion ein also solche
medikamente die medikamente sind
meistens verschreibungspflichtig und
deshalb nehmen die konsumenten ein
großes risiko auf sich das internet
bietet inzwischen zahlreiche unseriöse
wege an um medizinische produkte zu
kaufen dackelblick ich würde mal sagen
endlich erforscht japanische forscher
stießen durch urin proben nach einem
experiment von mensch und und auf einen
veränderten hormon spiel grund dafür
soll allein der blickkontakt zwischen
den menschlichen und tierischen
probanden gewesen seien gestiegen ist
der anteil des oxytocin hormons oxytocin
ist primär für
bindungs gefühle verantwortlich und
tritt besonders stark bei der geburt
auch besonders auffallend tritt eine
derartige veränderung des hormonspiegels
bei stillenden müttern und ihrem
säugling auf der spiegel steigt sowohl
beim kind als auch bei der mutter sobald
es beginnt an der mutterbrust zu saugen
was genau zwischen hund und mensch
passiert wenn sie sich in die augen
schauen
das erklärten die forscher um nijhof
nakazawa der fachzeitschrift science mit
30 hundehaltern führten sie das
experiment durch alle sollten ihren
tieren direkt in die augen sehen und
nach einiger zeit stoppten die
wissenschaftler den kontakt und nahmen
urinproben der probanden analysiert
wurde dann der oxytocin anteil vor dem
versuch war dieser nennenswert geringer
die hunde wurden dann durch wölfe
ausgetauscht und wieder sollten die
probanden sich direkt in die augen
blicken nach einer erneuten urinprobe
konnten keine veränderung des spiegels
vor und danach festgestellt werden
ja was ist schuld daran die
domestizierung der hunde mache diese
hormonausschüttung möglich wodurch die
menschen eine beziehung zu den tieren
aufbauen kennen können im gegensatz zu
dem wohl wölfen die ähnliche hormonelle
wechselwirkung zwischen mensch und hund
und mutter und kind könne erklären warum
hundebesitzer eine so starke beziehung
zu ihrem tier haben unbeachteter vulkan
zu den drei bedrohlichsten vulkan im
land chile gehört unter anderem der karl
buckow obwohl er als so gefährlich
angesehen wird wurde er kaum unter
langzeitbeobachtung stellt nun wachte er
nach gut 42 jahren auf und stiess
immense massen von rauch und asche aus
unerwartet traf der vulkan das land
keiner hatte mit einem ausbruch
gerechnet grund dafür
die entwicklung hat buches wurde eben
nicht sonderlich verfolgt rodrigo
benaglio innenminister von chile ließ
rund 1500 bewohner rund um den vulkan
evakuieren der geologe gabriel orozco
nen warnt davor dass die mengen in der
luft unter ihrem eigenen gewicht
zusammenbrechen könnten
und es zu einem pyroklastischen strom
kommt als pyroklastischen strom
bezeichnet man einen aus gasförmig und
feste nadal bestehenden auswurf des
vulkans dieser strom kann eine
höchstgeschwindigkeit von 300
stundenkilometern und temperaturen bis
rund 800 grad celsius erreichen er ist
absolut tödlich die frage warum man
einen der drei bedrohlichsten vulkane
das lande so unbeobachtet liest das ist
allerdings die ist noch nicht
beantwortet diese frage durchbruch in
der medizin und zwar bei der asthma
forschung wissenschaftler haben in der
fachzeitschrift science translational
medicine
eine studie veröffentlicht die
inhalatoren zukünftig für
asthmapatienten irrelevant machen könnte
die erkenntnisse der studie wurden mehr
oder weniger zufällig gewonnen bei der
genaueren analyse von osteoporose einer
skelett erkrankungen fielen den
forschern besonders gelegene rezeptoren
ins auge
sie liegen in der luftröhre diese art
von rezeptoren sind bereits der medizin
bekannt dagegen unbekannt war die lage
und genau diese macht die entdeckung der
rezeptoren für die asma forschung so
bedeutsam eine dysfunktion dieser ist
nämlich medikamentös behandelbar
kalcsics so werden die medikamente
bezeichnet setzen die rezeptoren außer
gefecht
unter eben genau solche beeinflussbaren
rezeptoren in der luftröhre auftauchen
könnte man nun sämtliche symptome einer
asthma-erkrankung auslöschen durch den
einsatz von kalzit typ ticks würde man
die rezeptoren abstellen und verhindern
dass sich die luftröhre zusammenzieht
bzw sich entzündet diese behandlung
ersetzt einen inhalator und/oder
steroide vollkommen und gewährleiste
eine wesentlich bessere prävention auch
der geldbeutel würde sich darüber
ziemlich freuen
die kleinen moleküle sind nämlich
billiger als steroide und definitiv
billiger als eine behandlung mit
antikörpern so daniela rica wie von der
uni weg
derzeit wird nach finanziellen mitteln
gesucht um die forschung zu finanzieren
die ersten versuche sollen schon
nächstes jahr bzw 2017 gestartet werden
dabei möchten die forscher unter anderem
auch klären ob man kalt ticks bei
chronischen lungenerkrankung oder auch
bronchitis einsetzen kann
immer wieder gibt es in letzter zeit
solche durchbrüche in der medizin krebs
durch eine masernimpfung spontan geheilt
werden kann
seht ihr in diesem video krebs spontan
geheilt zum app nähe zur app und zum
blog hier täglich wissenschaft news
asthma ist ja schon eine lange
existierende erkrankung ich habe es
übrigens auch würde mich tierisch
darüber freuen und wohl schon bald eben
nicht mehr so schwierig zu behandeln
welche entwicklungen in der medizin
könnt ihr euch denn in naher zukunft
vorstellen und von welcher
bahnbrechenden entwicklung in der
medizin habt ihr schon gehört
wunderheilungen allerdings
ausgeschlossen also schreibe es in die
kommentare und ansonsten ließ dann
bleibt dran